[Musique]
alors qui porte le coup de gueule ces
gens me une fois ce n'est pas vous
exempté je suis étonné allait à coup de
gueule contre christophe alévêque qui
était invitée dimanche chez drucker et
qui sous couvert de d'être humoriste
voilà s'est permis une blague plus que
douteuse sur -d nous l'a 9 chef bien
aimé en disant qu en sous-entendant de
façon très très lourde que s'il était
dans cet état de surexcitation
permanente pour ceux qui le connaissent
il est tout le temps comme ça voilà
était dû au fait qu'ils consomment des
substances illicites
alors c'est je trouve ça très très grave
c'est de la diffamation pure et dure
il laissa sous couvert d'humour comme ça
qu'on ne peut pas balancer les jeunes
ont balancé des choses comme ça va pas
les choses comme ça seulement pour
essayer de faire un bon mot qui détaille
ont même pas drôle d'à mais pour ceux
qui connaissent à tout petit peu il
devrait plus connaître ce qui je crois
que déjà venu ici devrait savoir que
cyril au contraire ça c'est maintenant
un athlète de haut niveau ses affaires
au temps d'antenne et cetera
ils ne boivent jamais d'alcool ne fume
pas il fait du sport tous les jours et
six arrivées acier bois sont pressés
volvic franklin qui est contre eux
d'hawaii sahel montreuil sur ille parce
que j'en sais quelque chose puisque bon
maintenant il ya prescription
pratiquement mais il ya deux ans j'ai eu
le malheur de céder dans une soirée un
peu plus festive que les autres à une
consommation qu'il est illégal et je
j'ai ainsi pu les jeunes évidemment à ne
pas le faire j'ai eu la chatte
évidemment de me faire chopper en
sortant de cette soirée la chance ou la
malchance ne me faire arrêter par amel
chaussée ce qui a été à bien pour moi
que du coup ça veut dire oui j'ai été
j'ai fait une garde à vue et j'étais
convoqué le lendemain par cyril et je
peux vous dire que la garde à vue était
bien désagréable douce que le quart
d'heure je n'ai pas ces extraits le
milan gênes donc quand vous verrez un
alcoolique engueuler un autre alcoolique
en bois vous m'appellerez ça n'arrive
jamais donc le but la sauce qui m'a mis
je pense qu'il n'a jamais touché une
drogue de sa vie donc on va regarder
l'extrait en question c'était donc dans
vivement dimanche et en fait pour
expliquer cette mauvaise blague
enora malagré était donc l'invité que ça
n'allait me fait un beau monde au club
depuis qu'elle était partie de
l'émission s'il était un peu en
dépression donc il prenait du xanax qui
vous c'était pas non plus et alévêque a
su organiser cac à son avis pour les
choses bien plus forte que ça c'est
assez nul mais on vos mots des images
alors comment ça s'est passé avec cyril
n'a pas été trop triste que technique
tpm p
si bien sûr il ne s'en est pas remis il
est actuellement sous xanax non mais on
est on est partisane à que c'était
gentil non mais on savoure
voilà donc c'est une mauvaise blague
elle aurait quand même et la justice
avec ec2 vous l'avez dit cyril c'est le
mec le plus saint que je connaisse au
monde
c'est incroyable s'est jamais un
excellent accueil en bois jamais il est
des douanes alors c'est vrai qu'il est
ils sont plusieurs dans sa tête c'est
vrai mais c'est naturel il est impératif
philibert actifs alors qu'en charente et
je suis entendu engueuler ya pas
longtemps un jeune en disant j'espère
que tu prends rien parce que nous je te
préviens nous on déteste ça on ne tolère
pas ça donc je la sentais juste ou et
sur service public ça donc ça c'est
inadmissible monsieur alévêque qui n'a
jamais été drôle de sa vie doivent
s'excuser en bonne et due forme très
rapidement on peut pas laisser passer à
temps alors